so I recently set myself the challenge
of finding the worst game on Steam I do
this on occasion just because I'm
curious of what is actually at the
bottom of the barrel and when I set out
for this challenge I didn't want to just
go looking for a game that was meant to
be bad because there are games like that
all over the place they're made
specifically to be bad and that can
sometimes be funny but often time is
just crap for the sake of being crap
what I wanted to find was a game that
had all the hope of being good and then
despite the developers best efforts
turned out to be the worst thing ever
and there's different criteria for that
number one I wanted to actually cost
money I wanted to actually spend money
on this so I could be disappointed by
the end result and number two I wanted
something that kind of hit on a few
different topics it wasn't just game
breakingly bad no I didn't want
something that was super buggy
incredibly just crap I wanted something
that was actually in the gameplay itself
terrible and I found it
they really found it so the first victim
of my search was a game called drug wars
and I actually came across some
interesting trivia buying this one this
was a hyped up game but if you haven't
heard of drug wars you wouldn't be
surprised it wasn't originally called
that it was called merchants of Brooklyn
it came out in 2009 and was this hyped
up game that some people even
pre-ordered apparently but when it came
out it was so unbelievably bad that they
changed the name to try to appeal to
something more and I couldn't even play
it so I can't judge it because the game
wouldn't even load up for me but some of
the accompanying material and gameplay
footage which you'll find here in front
of you can showcase that it's not
exactly the best game in the world but
by its steam rating of 33% it's also not
the worst so I gave it a pass the other
game that I tried to play was called
tunnel rats and this was a very low
rated game on Steam like the other one
at 34 percent but this one was about the
gripping reality of the Vietnam War
showcasing a side of it that didn't work
but unfortunately after a brief opening
segment it didn't work as well so I was
left with another game on my list and I
had a few more but I don't think I
needed to go any farther
this game is skyscraper simulator and
you think that this game would be cool
it looks like Euro Truck Simulator those
types of games and and oddly enough this
game is made by someone who makes those
types of games with other games like
agricultural simulator industry
simulator agricultural simulator 2013
agricultural simulator historical
farming which has a 12% farming diet
which has a 19% and then this game which
has the lowest score I've ever seen on
Steam at a whopping six percent and I'm
sure there is lower rated games but not
many there can't be many other people
said things such as this never played it
because it always crashes the desktop
after the dev logo 8 to 10 because I
like my wallpaper I love this game my
doctor gave me a prescription for ambien
to help me fall asleep but I just fire
up skyscraper
simulator instead and save so much money
on prescriptions to help me sleep
thanks skyscraper simulator while
playing I decided to wash the dishes it
was more entertaining than playing the
game
no one even drives to stupid things one
smelly sandy out of ten my immersion is
broken this might be my shortest review
ever this might be a game you enjoy if
you enjoy watching nothing happening at
various different speeds of play
appreciate the novelty of trucks
bouncing back and forth but nothing else
happens you find 10 workers needed to
drive a cement truck is feasible
watching paint dry is your ultimate
hobby however you shouldn't buy it if
you were hoping for a fun Tycoon game
you expect a more modern take of sim
tower you like fun graphics from 1980
hired 19,000 engineers and lost all my
25 million euros even though I couldn't
see a single engineer 19 out of 10 lost
all my money because I hired 10,000
workers when I only needed 25 9 out of
10 would play again
I've been reserving this designation for
a very special once-in-a-lifetime game
and I think this is it literally the
worst game I've ever played recommending
it for a once-in-a-lifetime experience
truly shows what it's like to be a
skyscraper slightly less boring than
staring at a wall 3.4 hours this was
bought as a joke but no joke I loved it
except it didn't start up for the first
nine months and the save button doesn't
work getting that fine balance between
delivering construction stuffed and
building and Wow twenty point nine hours
on record so you have to take into
account this game has a 6 percent rating
with all of these joke thumbs up that is
how bad this game is that being said I
played it
I played through it I went at it with
positivity in my mind I went at it
without any negativity in my soul I
thought that I was gonna give it an
honest try and I can honestly say I was
warned so if any of you are doing
anything that requires you to stay awake
I recommend that you don't watch the
next few minutes of this video because
it only gets more boring from here so
here is skyscraper simulator enjoy oh
that's good stuff alright
Oh welcome to skyscraper simulator this
is the city view in this view you can
buy sell and rent properties okay
ah oh I couldn't really see deep into
the earth I'm not sure why I why is the
music like that oh whatever
I'll go with I'll go with Baxter I like
the name battle okay oh well why isn't
it shown then oh whatever
oh okay
height low on funds okay well let's not
do that sure oh all right
you need to switch to the construction
site view Oh silly Samantha Pookie
Aubrey mammoth Samuel mammoth Anna
strong Lillian crude Jaden silly Sophia
silly Nicholas small Robert narrow
Olivia what if page up left right plus -
okay
bye silly Samantha narrow Joseph MacDill
n' imma go with big Lillian tiny hailey
wet Jack Giga Natalie alright
silly Luca with Wyatt Hanna I guess all
right what do we got
what are the arrows mean excavation Sage
Foundation sage construction taters
start first by one excavator and one
dumper well I did sign some workers to
the administration team to reduce the
monthly Wow Human Resources there we go
engineers foremen workers foundation
administrative administrative is this
Addington are we going oh hi hello Wow
what are you doing what are you what are
you doing you are what is in there
whoa it's empty oh okay administrative
team maintenance crew ah waiting for
excavation two percent done okay I guess
I need more excavators Pookie Aubrey
mammoths annual you okay and then dump
trucks I guess soft Aiden
okay strong Christopher that's good I'll
get the others later I guess okay
there's some more they're not oh there
oh there they go oh look at him go there
we need more workers as far as I'm
understanding nope what
okay that's good I guess okay more on
Pookie Aubrey okay ah ah okay we're
doing great work
I think we're flying now there we go
there we go that's how you do it okay
when does the fun start oh my god this
is somehow worse than watching this
happen in real time this is somehow like
if you were standing outside of a
construction site and you were watching
them build it that would be more
interesting than what's happening right
now okay I'm not gonna get critical
about this game just yet because I don't
know what they're doing okay hang on oh
wait okay the dumpy truck OHS they don't
have workers either we don't have enough
workers we need more workers let's just
get a bunch of workers that sounds
pretty good I like the sound of that
I like workers workers are good well let
me see if I can snatch one of these
things there we go grab you oh yeah
let's crank that up now we should be oh
look at that go I think it's better I'm
not a hundred percent sure but I think
that's better is that better so will you
call better and again why can I see so
deep how am I gonna be digging down
there am I gonna find some bodies buried
under here okay whatever I guess I can
start planning for the future but I
don't want to soft Sam you'll get in
here ah swift Samantha smart Alexa there
you go I don't know why we did that I've
got plenty of money I mean money doesn't
seem to be a big issue in this endeavor
if I knew it was this easy to build a
skyscraper I would have done it myself a
long time ago okay
I think we're getting close to done with
excavation which is great right boom
done wahoo why do we pause okay where
did that come from did that descend from
the heavens and just smash right
there get more workers in here
Foundation is underway I don't know what
they're doing
oh you're filling it back in we just dug
that out we just we just dug that out
didn't we all right I don't know I guess
there's I guess that's supposed to be
some man put it I just feel like all the
hard work that I just did is now done
laid away feel like you're just kind of
like mocking me now isn't is there some
way to see like my actual oh I see okay
here we go okay I got you
so I can see yeah yeah yeah yeah one two
three there we go okay yeah we're we're
we're gonna be going now does it take
away good it takes away the other
workers so I can just crank these up to
maximum right where's your performance
awful crude Christian what a screw crude
Christian give me a better one tiny
Jacob yeah tiny Jacob get in here I
don't know is there any punishment for
actually hiring this many things I have
no idea okay there we go
I don't know what we did what are we
doing what are we doing Oh what does
that even mean you're just raising up
this big weird obelisk lit appeared out
of the sky what is that okay whatever I
guess we're almost done and then we're
halfway through the finishing the
building is that what I'm supposed to
tell what I'm understanding about this
we're halfway done oh great
wait is that it wait is that wait is
this the whole thing but then why did we
what did we dig that hole also what did
you what oh there there you go all right
let's fill them up I guess trying to
fill up some more workers I guess we're
not building why are we not building
what do we need waiting on what waiting
on waiting on what what do we need
you're not telling me what we need you
it's just glowing red job steel skeleton
Oh
is that what we're supposed oh my god
this is the whole game oh my god this is
the whole game okay I don't know what
I'm supposed to do besides wait Here I
am honestly I'm trying to find what it
is I'm supposed to be doing there must
be some nascent satisfaction factor to
this concept right there there has to be
right there would have to be would
anyone play this game in normal speed if
you're playing this game in normal speed
it's already been one year forty four
weeks three days on the dot every hour
is one second so if I must tell my
calculator here all the time that we
just spent here if you were playing this
in normal speed you'd be sitting here
for four and a half hours just play on
fast I still don't understand why we dug
that gigantic hole for this building I
feel like I'm also not playing the game
right because I probably hired way too
many workers and I probably haven't been
tossing them around efficiently between
machines I haven't been buying the right
machines but I've still got 14 million
euros and if I am playing it wrong then
you would have to play this a lot more
slowly because you wouldn't have as many
workers working on your skyscraper and
therefore it would take longer there's
nothing else for me to do at this point
I'm literally just sitting around I mean
I want to see it done I want to see it
done I'm hoping that there's gonna be
some kind of a satisfaction out of it I
mean maybe you could multitask and do
other projects at once but I don't think
I have the money for it I guess and
we're really moving fast now and that's
good
this is the most direct equivalent to
watching paint dry I've ever seen in a
game and I'm not trying to say that like
I'm not coming at this game trying to be
insulting about it I mean look at what
paint drying is you look at a wall and
you wait and watch as my new changes
happen over a long period of time and
compare that to what I'm doing in this
game done took two years seventeen weeks
and 16 hours all right what now so
there's no management system of rent or
ah there it's just plus or minus again
so this
am i making money and I'm I did I'm I am
I made money okay so I guess the next
thing to do would be to build another
one oh but that's too expensive I can't
I don't have enough money I have to wait
until I get money okay I think I'm good
I think I think I think I'm good
leaderboard no one's on the leaderboard
okay
I'm good I'm real good
so that was arguably the worst game on
Steam and I say that not from broken
controls because oddly enough the
controls worked
not from glitchy gameplay because at the
end of it I did build a skyscraper and I
guess it was a simulation of what it's
like to be a skyscraper but at the same
time it wasn't fun it wasn't a happy
time I had no idea why I was even there
and frankly I'm sad that I wasted my
life trying to figure out why they dug
that big of a hole for that small of a
skyscraper but either way that is the
worst game that I found on Steam I'm
sure that I'll find another because I'm
sure that you guys know about worse
games on Steam so if you know of a game
that's worse than this one let me know
down in the comments below I will go
through the process of reviewing it
myself and I will show you how probably
right you are so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye
[Music]